hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video ihr seht schon im titel
eingeblendet der schlimmste horror film
an bevor ich allerdings darüber rede was
es damit auf sich hat muss sich noch
ganz kurz zu drei sachen etwas sagen
nochmals ihr seht wahrscheinlich schon
dieses kissen dahinden
dieses kissen wir dieses kissen ist
gestern emster wiener von d zusammen mit
26 mio t shirts gelauncht und es war ein
ultra krank als freunde werden nie mit
so einer riesigen nachfrage gerechnet
deswegen die erste sache zu der ich kurz
zu sagen möchte geht quasi über dieses
kissen und zwar gestern gelaunten es
haben so viele tausende leute bestellt
das wenn man jetzt bestellt das kissen
erst gegen ende juli anfang august
geliefert bekommt das tut er leider
bewährten halt wirklich damit gerechnet
dass so viele das bestellen als
wiedergutmachung da fahren wir uns jetzt
überlegt dass wir das vielleicht zu
machen dass es immer am ersten tag eines
monats also erst der ju die erste august
die et cetera immer 1000 signierte flyer
beziehungsweise sticker geht andere
youtuber machen das so dass es dauerhaft
autogrammkarten zu den bestellungen gibt
davon bin ich überhaupt kein fan weil
ich hasse es wenn autogrammkarten
einfach kopiert werden die ganze zeit
weil dann und machte einmal unterschrift
daran hat jeder die gleiche ich mag halt
lieber wenn ich dann ab und zu aktionen
mache wie das beispielsweise immer am
ersten tag eines monats eine
unterschrift offenen sticker kommt und
dann gibt's da von 1000 stück und so
bleibt das so als wiedergutmachung was
haltet ihr davon
es ist der sache die ich euch kurz
fragen beziehungsweise sagen wollte ich
bin hier voll deutschland supporter
geworden
nur mal zwei ich wollte mich für das mit
mir auf der couch ein video
entschuldigen was ich vor ein zwei drei
tagen hochgeladen habe weil ich habe
sehr viele leute angesprochen die man
mich an einen dieser weniger
angesprochen aber ich sag das jetzt
einfach mal so weit weil ich mich aber
irgendwie unwohl für das hoch geladen zu
haben das war immer wieder dating
simulator dagegen ein bisschen in die
plus 8 in richtung und ich habe darauf
jetzt auch eine altersbeschränkung
bekommen ich meine mit youtube und mir
ist der tee nicht so als ich hatte
letztens schon strike bekommen
und dieses videos jetzt halt wieder als
plus 18 freigegeben also damit ich von
euch das video mal hier ich weiß nicht
ob ich das dann angucken können ihr
müsst dafür acht sein ich wollte mich
nur dafür entschuldigen dass ich etwas
hochgeladen habe und ich werde das nie
wieder so was komisches machen sachen
nummer drei ich habe ja letztens schon
bei meinem snap chipcount laser luca ein
video gemacht wo ich einen ball im weg
wer von eines der nächsten szene immer
den korb geflogen
sowas habe ich bei facebook sehen dies
mit einer flasche gemacht wurde und
typischer lokal sehr neugierig wollte
das auch wieder ausprobiert deswegen
habe ich das auch nicht so ein bisschen
gemein ich hab's diesmal echt nicht so
lange gemacht wie man das netz ist euer
letztes mal dass ich wirklich eine
minute lang gegen was wohin gebraucht
war oder so habe ich wollte einfach
testen wie es aussieht deswegen denke
ich euch das jetzt hier einfach mal ein
was ich mit dieser flasche gemacht habe
weitere zeiten einig dass er wichtig
fand jetzt meine lieben freunde kommen
wir zur sache weswegen hier das video
wahrscheinlich angeklickt hat und was
dem titel gelesen hab nämlich der
schlimmste horror film das ganze muss
ich allerdings an dieser stelle dazu
sagen ist kein placement werbevideo
produktplatzierungen werbung et cetera
für diesen kinofilm weil ich gesehen
habe dass sehr viele youtube als
placement gemacht haben sondern es
einfach nur meine meinung
ja es geht nicht um den horrorfilm der
konzern zwei ich habe dazu vorher schon
berichte auf facebook gelesen von wegen
der film ist echt krass verstörend wenn
sie hilfe brauchen suchen sie einen
priester auf und so ist soll echten ja
es ist ein sehr krasser horrorfilm will
dafür überhaupt keine werbung machen ich
bin noch überhaupt kein horrorfilm fan
also allein die tatsache dass ich das
letzte mal ein horror film geguckt habe
vor sieben jahren zeit so ein bisschen
das ist das eigentlich nicht so oft
mache vor sieben jahren habe ich halt
den film scream geguckt und hatte danach
sieben tage lang komplett überhaupt
nicht schlafen und habe jetzt noch
teilweise so visionen irgendwie dafür in
sicht
ich hasse horrorfilme jedenfalls bin ich
vergessen habe mit freunden ins kino
gegangen haben uns überlegt ob wir
gucken deshalb intelligence oder diesen
moneymaker glaube ich oder halt bekommen
gering 2 und 6 2
haltinner haben schon angefangen
deswegen haben wir gedacht wir gucken
den war so eine scheiße entscheidung
weil ich habe alles schon vorher gesagt
ja ich kann überhaupt keine horrorfilme
ab und jetzt ist es das erste mal in
sieben jahren dass ich wieder den
horrorfilm gehe deswegen werde ich meine
reaktion einfach mal so ein bisschen
filme gespielt hat
zwei taxen
ich bin gut ist dass der schaffe das
ding zu überleben das war quasi die
erste aufnahme die ich im kino gemacht
habe dann haben wir halt noch 20 minuten
gewartet
sie müssten nicht los und ihr müsst
wissen wir mal einen kinobesuch heute
sich vielleicht kleines eis und eine
kleine schachtel popcorn oder was zu
trinken oder so das haben wir uns geholt
wir haben uns netz schoss popcorn und
jungen betrinken einmal geholt und
minuten später kam mit halb franzose hat
deutsche rein und haben uns auch noch
mal irgendwas gesagt also den weiterhin
gegen die sowas ja hallo ich die tiere
raumtemperatur hier in ordnungen und
jahres läuft oder der reha der film ist
nichts für schwache nerven wegen die
monster ag schließen und irgend so ein
schwachsinn und da dachte ich mir schon
so war okay kam kein typ der gesagt hat
der film ist nichts für schwache nerven
wenn man angst hat seinen augen zu
machen ich hab jetzt schon ein
dann kam also typische kinowerbung hat
nur von horrorfilm für die scheiße also
ich hab mir allein bei der bergung wurde
die hose gefasst ich war wirklich bei
der werbung richtig froh wenn du scheiß
werbung für ein auto oder für eiskalt
ich bin eine komplette ein scheiß hose
mache ich kann so was echt nicht ab bis
10.000 meter noch ein flugzeug springen
lasse mich in wales über die längste
seilbahn mit 180 km/h fahren lasse mich
trampolinspringen bristol mit im wiener
höhle darunter war regelmäßig 300.000 km
habe die autobahn und haben nix angst
aber bei horrorfilm vor das echt ende
alter von dann den halt der film los und
dann kam auch noch mal der typ reihen
und einseitigen wieso jahre viel spaß
beim filmen und alle so yeah hh danke
danke und er dazu ja jetzt lacht er noch
wie die einbindung ich glaube das jahr
jetzt lacht ihr noch habe ich sogar mit
aufgenommen oder so
das war quasi genau und 20 uhr an
löffeln los gegen die nächste aufnahme
war dann um 22 uhr 12 und zwar weil da
dann quasi der film vorbei ja das habe
ich dann da halt gesagt film ist vorbei
mein leben braucht
alter schwede
diese könnten film gesehen wenn sich
dann aus dem kino wieder raus war bolt
dann noch mal so ein bisschen das ganze
revue passieren lassen jetzt aus dem
kino aus ich bin immer noch folge flash
bis wissen ich weiß er genau sieben
jahren nicht mehr dem horrorfilm damals
habe ich scream shout und da war es halt
so dass rest komischer typ was das für
komische typ 4 durch luca in der
nächsten kleine blende und dass ich
gerade die aufnahme abgebrochen habe
aber wir standen vor verschlossenen
parkhaus das ist okay danke schön
überhaupt gehört mai stand vor
verschlossenen parkhaus weil das volk
von 190 30 aufwärts und dem film ging
aber bis 10
das müssen wir noch 30 euro für die
schweiz wieder bezahlen da noch das
parkticket pächterin holm wir haben ein
paar kosten der bielefelder innenstadt
geparkt was nur bis 20 oder 30 auf hatte
und wir waren irgendwie so halbes kilo
sg geld wir sind jetzt hier gerade im
leeren parkhaus zusammen mit unserem
auto steht hier noch dieses eine andere
auto aus herford person es ist halt
wirklich alles leer und nur wir waren
die einzigen volltrottel den nicht auf
das ticket 30 euro bezahlen dafür dass
der typ ist das dorf gemacht hat dann
noch mal zehn euro fürs parkdeck war ein
sehr teurer abend auf jeden fall leipzig
einem auto saß habe ich alle noch mal so
eine zusammenfassung vom film gemacht
ich war echt also mal den film zusammen
zu fassen ich war wirklich gerade schon
gesagt seit sieben jahren nicht mehr dem
horrorfilm war ich früher screen geguckt
habe und danach hatte ich eine woche
lang albträumen konnte ich nicht richtig
schlafen deswegen hab ich halt nie
wieder ein horrorfilm angerührt habe
immer das eine kacke kommt zur ableger
wie scary movie und so und jetzt waren
wir in der kölner ring 2 und ich muss
wirklich sagen dass du schaltest du ihn
welt
ich muss sagen der film ist
unrealistisch gingen dem mond und malz
die hoffentlich nicht gibt aber es war
halt ich weiß nicht ich hatte halt diese
momente ein horrorfilm wo es darum geht
ok die kamera leuchtet auf ihn
er guckt sich irgendwo rum kommt wieder
regnen dann steht da irgendeiner und man
rechnet einfach gar nicht damit und das
ist wahrscheinlich sagt jeder experte
gerade so auch der firma der volkacher
aber mich als übels mitgenommen ich
wollte erfahrung mit euch teilen
das also mich hat der film wird genommen
und dann lag ich halt noch im bett ich
weiß nicht ich jetzt hier schon seit 20
minuten im bett und denke über den film
nach ich weiß nicht nur normalerweise
ist und ich glaube alle horror leute
sagen ich ziehe luca wieso nimmt sich
der film so mehr ich bin halt kein otto
normal horrorfilm schaue mich
beschäftigt das mal so ein bei mir so
ich träume immer von den sachen die mich
am tag viel beschäftigt haben das habe
ich jede einzelne nacht deswegen habe
ich kann echt angst sich von der scheiße
träume allerdings kann ich da eine
warnung geben ich habe nicht mit dem
horrorfilm geträumt zu haben und dann
alle die jetzt vielleicht daniel otto
bisher voll das war ich ein geht bitte
selber in den film rein ist soll
wirklich gar keine werbung sei irgendein
kino englisch statt für den film et
cetera ich werde hierfür nichts bezahlen
aber der film war echt krass gut und man
kann ja auch mal so werbung für etwas
machen wo man kein geld für bekommen ich
wollte einfach nur meinen kinobesuch bei
einem horror film in dem ich jetzt seit
sieben jahren mal wieder rahmen euch
teilen und habe mir gedacht vielleicht
wird sich während des noch mal so ein
bisschen gefilmt habe ich weiß nicht das
video überhaupt den sinn hatte war mehr
so info video mit bisschen story real
life ball aber wenn es euch trotzdem
gefahren habe ich mich sehr über eine
bewertung freuen dieses bisher story
real life gelaber ihr könnt das kissen
immer noch im
kuka shop bestellen müssen damit ein
bisschen wartezeit rechnen aber es ist
halt nicht
ace ist so flauschig man wir sehen uns
morgen den nächsten video wieder ab 299
schönen tag freunde viel spaß euch noch
an diesem wundervollen es ist nur im
regen draußen ist